stop stop during a police chase near
Green Bay Wisconsin an officer is shot
with his own gun a Sig Sauer P320 while
getting out of his Cruiser
Huffington Post reports there have been
more than 100 instances across the
country where owners of the P320 claim
their guns went off without pulling the
trigger I'm Anjanette Levy and thanks
for joining us here on Law and crime the
Sig Sauer P320 is used by officers at
many police departments across the
country in fact the U.S military has
issued it to service members in several
branches of the military the P320 is a
relatively newer gun it's been
manufactured since 2014. a number of
police officers are suing Sig Sauer over
the P320 firing without the trigger
being pulled according to the trace
which bills itself as a newsroom
dedicated to covering gun violence the
P320 has been the subject of many
complaints since 2017 that it can fire
if dropped
in December of last year Hobart Lawrence
Police Officer Sam Schroeder was part of
a Chase his body camera captured his Sig
Sauer P320 firing when he got out of his
vehicle
deal it was me I need a tourniquette
I got you I got you
if you slow down the video of Officer
Schrader's body camera you can see his
P320 in his hand that's a different
situation from the other claims about
the pistol that said the P320 sometimes
fired while fully holstered
Steve Wolfe is an armorer and a Firearms
expert Steve thanks for coming on tell
us a little bit about what were your
thoughts when you first heard about this
issue with the Sig Sauer P320
the first thing I thought was how sad it
was that people were getting injured
because of a possible design defect in a
gun and that's not really because of the
gun it's because people let guns point
to things that they don't want to see
bullets in
no part of gun safety is based on the
reliability of the gun it's based on the
operator so when we say never allow a
gun to point at anything you don't want
to destroy that would take care of a
situation where a gun might
inadvertently fire Alec and therefore
you are the safety not the equipment
there's a presumption that any piece of
equipment could fail in this case it's
particularly sad to me that it was a
that it was a Sig striker-fired gun
because
my bedside gun that I'd get through the
zombie apocalypse is also a Sig
generally Sig makes the most reliable
firearms on the planet these things are
just absolutely no pun intended but
bulletproof and extremely reliable but
with a striker-fired gun like the 320
everything that makes the gun work is
inside and you can't really see what's
going on when you chamber around you're
actually you know pre-caulking the
striker that fires it that the fire pin
is now cocked and then all of the that
the trigger does is simply release it
but you can't really see any of that
process where with a a gun with an
external Hammer like this
you can see when the gun is cocked you
can decock the gun and when you press
the trigger you're actually cocking it
so there's no Force against the pin
until you press the trigger to pull the
hammer back and then release it so
maybe it's because of my age but I
prefer guns that are older and have been
around a little bit longer where all of
the bugs have been worked out I don't
think any of my guns are newer than 30
years old so this was a newer gun this
model issued in 2014 many branches of
the US military carry this gun or issue
it to their service members police
officers carry this gun and we have you
know 100 or so people saying I had this
gun I carried it and it discharged
without me pulling the trigger they're
suggesting there's a design flaw what
are your thoughts on that
that sounds entirely plausible based on
the evidence that there have been over
100 cases of people reporting this
particular gun to have fired
unintentionally and you're not hearing
reports about that on other guns but the
exception of the rust movie set so the
the 320 and any gun in Alex hands are
probably the most dangerous and uh
certainly the Sig looks like it has a
design flaw should Sig Sauer be
basically recalling this firearm I mean
what do you think the manufacturer
should be doing I think the manufacturer
should do a design recall on that
particular model they should evaluate
what is causing this Striker to release
without the trigger being depressed and
then they should fix that and reissue it
they don't have a problem with any of
their other models and neither do any
other manufacturers so this problem
seems to be isolated to this one model
from this manufacturer Sig Sauer is
offering a voluntary upgrade program
allowing current P320 odors to trade in
their gun for a newer modified model Sig
sauer's website says the program was
implemented after testing confirmed
quote that usually after multiple drops
at certain angles and conditions a
potential discharge of the firearm may
result when dropped the site also says
the newer pistols have an alternate
design that reduces the physical weight
of the trigger Seer and Striker while
additionally adding a mechanical
disconnector
for officer Sam Schroeder's pistol in
Hobart Lawrence a Milwaukee TV station
reports an examination of the weapon
revealed it could not fire without
pulling the trigger but that
Department's officers are no longer
using the P320 I reached out to Sig
Sauer for comment so far I have not
heard back but the company's website
insists the P320 is safe for Law and
crime I'm Anjanette Levy